president joe biden is furious that the
state of texas has voted to limit
abortion and he is ready to wield the
full weight of the federal government to
stop it according to biden quote the
supreme court's overnight ruling is an
unprecedented assault on constitutional
rights and requires an immediate
response we will launch a whole of
government effort to respond looking at
what steps we can take to ensure that
texans have access to safe and legal
abortions he calls it an overnight
decision as as though it was rushed it
was illegitimate somehow if it were a
daytime decision that'd be fine this was
an ordinary supreme court decision
to observe that a state is allowed to
pass a law and it'll work its way
through the courts it doesn't even rule
on the constitutionality of the law
all
to kill more babies
that's what all of this is about all of
this outrage all of this effort
to stop some
kids from living
our senile
allegedly devout catholic president of
the united states mustered more energy
and clarity of purpose than he has at
any point in his presidency more than
any point probably in the last five
years
to stop
a state
from letting kids live
how sick is that
what kind of a psycho is this guy
what kind of a psycho country have we
become i'm michael knowles it's the
michael knowles show
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment yesterday from zoe glass who
says michael you have it all wrong biden
is a genius he is following in obama's
footsteps by picking a vice president so
inept that no one would dare impeach him
i'm sure that's what he was thinking
part of it was the identity politics
he's had to pick a black woman because
he backed himself into that corner and
the only options were karen bass who's
actually a communist or susan rice who
was the fall man on benghazi or kamala
harris who was the first person out of
the democratic
presidential primary but that's actually
a bonus for him at least in the latter
kamala didn't have a ton of dirt on her
in terms of her radicalism she's just
deeply unlikable and so yes it's true
one of the reasons i oppose impeachment
even beyond the constitutional legal
arguments
is that i don't want president harris
that's a good
that's a good
place to be in if you're the president
you know if you want to hedge your bets
i would strongly recommend you check out
acre gold inflation is through the roof
everything is more expensive i'm going
to go see my relatives this weekend i
tried to get a hotel the prices are way
way up but you know price of groceries
is up price of gas is up
great way to hedge against inflation
physical gold right now acre will let
you
start investing in physical gold for as
little as 30 a month michael you liar
hold on don't call me a liar michael
gold is more than that i stop it don't
call me a liar acre has come up with an
ingenious plan to let you invest in
physical gold without coming out of
pocket all at once you subscribe 30
bucks a month to their gold bars when
your gold stash reaches the price of
their gold bars they discreetly ship
acre gold to your house just this month
they introduced a 100 a month
subscription to a five gram gold bar if
you want to up the ante i have loved
investing in physical gold and fiscal
precious metals go visit getacregold.com
knowles right now start investing in
physical gold today
make sure you go to that url acres
giving away a gold bar to qualify for
the giveaway tweet or post why you
should be the recipient mentioned at get
underscore acre it's a free bar of gold
get acre gold dot com slash nols thank
you aker gold for supporting the show
the abortion response is scandalous
it is scandalous that of all of the
issues especially after this
absolute chaos pulling out of
afghanistan especially with inflation
going through the roof especially with
all of the domestic problems the
true crisis on the border millions of
illegal aliens flooding across we have
no idea who's coming over that allegedly
during a pandemic but these people
aren't even being tested for covid
just
crisis after crisis after crisis the
only one that has aroused the full
energy of the federal government
is a little law in texas that lets some
kids live that's scandalous
that is that is a
an impediment to to people's uh
understanding of the world i mean that's
really
a big problem and it's especially
scandalous because the president
allegedly is a devout catholic that's
all we hear from the mainstream media
he's a catholic he's a devout catholic
he goes to mass every sunday he's such a
catholic
but catholics
are not permitted to support
abortion so jinsaki please explain this
for me
what our effort and what the focus of
the federal government is is to look for
every resource every lever at our
disposal to ensure women in texas have
the ability to seek health care
following up on the census law why does
the president support abortion when his
own catholic faith teaches abortion is
morally wrong
he believes that it's a woman's right
it's a woman's body and it's her choice
why does the president of who does he
believe then should look out for the
unborn child he believes that it's up to
a woman to make those decisions and up
to a woman to make those decisions with
her doctor i know you've never faced
those choices nor have you ever been
pregnant but for women out there who
have faced those choices this is an
incredibly difficult thing president
believes their rights should be
respected go ahead i think we got to
move on so first of all i've been told
by the government for many months now
that men can become pregnant i've been
told that it's not just women who get
pregnant now it see there was a lot of
confusion over who gets pregnant for
many months now all of a sudden the
white house sees it clearly now that the
fictional right to abortion is being
threatened but i think saki just told on
herself i think saki just gave away the
game here because did you hear that last
sentence that she uttered she got very
emotional
borderline hysterical wouldn't answer
the question she says you you've never
been pregnant you that for women who
make this [ __ ] this is a very difficult
choice is it difficult
why is it a difficult choice
you're telling me
that abortion
is not
the taking of an innocent human life
you've been telling me for a long time
radical left that abortion it's just the
removal of a parasite it's just a clump
of cells it's it's
no different than getting your appendix
removed
so then why is it a difficult choice
if you're if your appendix needs to be
removed if you think that's best for
your health then that's a very easy
choice remove my appendix please easy i
don't need to worry about that i won't
face trauma after i've done that why is
abortion different why is it a difficult
choice because you know that it's the
ending of an innocent human life because
we all know it no matter how much we
want to suppress it we all have this
just nagging little feeling uh maybe
this is different why did hillary
clinton say that abortion should be safe
legal and rare why should it be rare if
it's just removing a parasite
if it's just your body your choice
because it's not because we all know
that it's not it's difficult because it
involves
people's natural understanding that this
is a baby and it is wrong to kill your
baby
and it also involves predators such as
abortionists such as
the
pro-abortion media such as joe biden and
jansaki and the liberal establishment
and the elected officials who are all
preying on the fears and anxiety of
women who get pregnant who don't know
what to do to just make it all go away
or at least pretend to make it all go
away by killing their baby that's why
it's difficult
it's a difficult decision because one
grapples with one's conscience on the
one hand and one's temptations on the
other that's why it's difficult you're
right you're right jen it is difficult
on the point of joe biden being catholic
what she is admitting here is that joe
biden is not a practicing catholic
to be a practicing catholic you cannot
support abortion
when when she says well look yeah joe's
catholic but he believes that a woman
has the right to kill her baby he isn't
she is admitting he's not a practicing
catholic and i know there's some
confusion on this point among certainly
among the left but even among
conservatives and they'll say well
michael you're just gatekeeping religion
well michael you're just nitpicking well
what you're holier than now you're
saying that someone can't be a catholic
if they don't agree with every single
thing
the catholic faith is different than
some other faiths
in that the catholic faith is
an incarnational faith that says that
there are real obligations and those
real obligations will be defined by real
people in a real church
that has real authority
to make you do certain things and if you
don't do certain things then
that church that real place led by real
people including a real pope has the
authority to define
that you are not practicing the faith
what i mean by that is this
you've got to do certain things there
are real sacraments you've got it you
actually do have to go to mass on sunday
but that's not enough you also have to
go to confession that's another
sacrament you also have to follow
the guidelines of the catholic church
the moral
demands of the catholic faith
and
some are more demanding than others so
one one objection i often hear is well
michael but the catholic church is
against the death penalty which is sort
of true but not totally true the
catholic church as a prudential matter
discourages the death penalty it says
it's inadmissible now even that's the
most radical language that's from pope
francis or that practically speaking it
shouldn't be performed
in most places
but as pope benedict said
quite well there can be a legitimate
disagreement among catholics thomas
aquinas defended the death penalty saint
paul defends the death penalty many
popes defended the death penalty blessed
pope pius ix carried out many death
penalties in the papal states obviously
there at the very least there can be
difference of opinion there cannot be a
difference of opinion on abortion
for 1900 years at least the catholic
church has taught clearly that abortion
is not
permissible you can't it is a
non-negotiable issue
so joe biden has to choose which faith
he wants to follow his catholic faith
that he tries to use to score political
points or his progressive faith which is
his actual religion and before you tell
me that a man's religion should have
nothing to do with his politics it
should have nothing to do with the way
he governs i will point out a man's gods
have everything to do with how he
governs everybody's got to serve
somebody and so his moral his ethical
his views of the of man's relationship
to
man to the state to god to metaphysics
that is going to define his government
the left knows this the left told us
this in the 1970s the feminists said the
personal is political personal choices
decisions behaviors have a political
effect and conservatives have made fun
of them but they're right they're right
and
they knew it then they don't want to
admit that it's true in this case as
well i think we should all admit that it
is right and we need to
question
what gods are our leaders serving what
has struck me about all of this and it
was actually a meme from my doppelganger
rachel maddow that showed me this is
that
the left really does not understand
where we're coming from here forget
about on questions of religion or even
the broader ethical questions i mean
even just on abortion they have no idea
what pro-lifers
believe there was a meme from rachel
maddow said if they make abortions
illegal they should make it illegal for
men to desert women after getting
pregnant if women can't back out of
pregnancies men shouldn't be able to
either
yep
conservatives on the one hand rachel
maddow on the other both agreeing
abolish no fault divorce absolutely we
totally agree with that
of course we don't think men should be
able to abandon women after they have
babies either they should take a little
more precaution before they
indulge in certain activities that
produce babies or once they do that they
should stick by the baby we all agree
with that the left doesn't even forget
about abortion for a second the left
doesn't even realize that that's how we
view human relationships that that's
what we're for
you know
this is the sort of thing that really
really gets your heart going
if you want good heart health i would
strongly recommend you check out super
beats if you want to live a long time
you got to keep your ticker working
right and so one thing i would strongly
recommend is super beets heart chews
they combine non-gmo beets with a
special ingredient grape seed extract
that is unique to super beets heart
chews
it's been the focus of scientific
research for years grape seed extract
has a high concentration of antioxidants
supports cardiovascular health and
overall wellness the grape seed extract
used in super beets heart chews has been
clinically shown to be two times as
effective at supporting normal blood
pressure as a healthy lifestyle alone
healthy blood flow means more energy
it's the way nature intended without all
that jittery caffeine or stimulants and
just two delicious chews a day gives the
blood pressure support that you need and
the energy that you want strongly
recommend this do what i did support
your heart health with delicious super
beets heart shoes get your super beats
heart chews today at superbeats.com
knowles when you buy two bags they will
throw in the third for free that is
superbeats.com
knowles
my doppelganger rachel maddow
highlighted a point that i think we all
know implicitly which is that the left
the the pro-abortion people really do
not understand where we're coming from
they really think that we just want to
punish women we hate women we don't we
don't want them to have the wonderful
liberating beautiful choice to kill a
baby and that's and it's all just about
being vindictive and mean we're all just
meanies right and
a friend of mine posted on twitter
yesterday he said you know this rachel
maddow meme is going right it just
really shows that neither side
understands the other but i don't think
that's true i don't think that's true
and actually some research from jonathan
height
the social scientist kind of backs this
up
i agree that the left doesn't understand
where we're coming from on abortion
but i think that i do understand where
the and i think we broadly understand
where the pro-abortion people are coming
from i get it
you think
that if
a woman is to be equal and indiscernible
from a man she can't have this natural
difference whereby she's the one who can
get pregnant and a man can't even though
the left is now sort of denying that
also except when abortion's in an issue
then they know who's pregnant
but they believe that for true gender
equality
a woman needs to be able to kill
her baby or they believe that it's not
really a baby if he can't talk or he's
not really a baby if he's not fully
formed or he's not he's just a clump of
cells
it's not it's not a big deal sure
the clump of cells is genetically
distinct and sure the clump of cells we
were all clumps of cells once and sure
it's it's a baby
you know it's a it's a at least a
pre-baby but
it's not a big deal don't worry he's not
going to feel any pain
i get it i used to support when i was a
teenager i was pro-abortion i just
assumed i didn't i didn't know anybody
who was pro-life it was the culture we
lived in so i get it but i don't think
we can just say well both sides need to
understand the other better i i think i
think the conservatives understand the
left and i think it is incumbent upon
the left to understand the right it's
important for the right to
persuade the left and to make our case
and then most importantly of all it's
important for us to wield political
power
because i don't think the left is going
to reconcile with us i don't think
they're going to come around i don't
even think they know what we believe i
don't think they know what they believe
there was a tweet yesterday from richard
henania he's a progressive think tank
president he tweeted out quote
you can't screen for down syndrome
before about 10 weeks and something like
80 of down syndrome fetuses are aborted
if red states ban abortion we would see
a world where they have five times as
many children with down syndrome and
similar numbers for other disabilities
the horror the horror that
people with disabilities might be
permitted to live could you imagine ugh
we'd have to look at them we'd have to
oh god we might even have to talk to
them could you imagine ugh they wouldn't
all be perfect you know like we are
we're so perfect not like them they're
defective they're ugh
yucky huh
he goes on could be outliers in the
whole developed world there are already
negative stereotypes of americans in
these states huh you get it ha they're
all they're all retards those [ __ ]
republicans down in the southern states
imagine if we had real retards running
around gosh that'd be terrible got to
keep killing them through abortion
one can imagine he writes
it getting much more extreme what if
they also ban genetic engineering and
embryo selection as we obviously should
use psycho
while other places go ahead oh god could
you imagine
we wouldn't we wouldn't all just be
perfect
we wouldn't all just be perfect
perfect like richard is doesn't he seem
perfect to you
oh a wonderful specimen
mentally physically and spiritually
right
i don't think so my friend spencer
clavin made this point yesterday we're
we are rightly disgusted by i mean this
is sick psycho stuff
this is the norm okay this is the norm
richard henania is the norm eugenics is
the norm
trying to kill off the weak trying to
kill off people who might have some more
visible problems and others that's the
norm in human society child sacrifice is
the norm in human society
then
you have
in the old testament you see in in
judaism a turn away from human sacrifice
a taking of the side of the victim
rather than of the community that tries
to sacrifice the victim and then you see
the fullness of this in christianity
which says no
no we're not doing that and the reason
that we in the west have had a problem
with eugenics where every other country
on earth every other culture on earth
has not
every other culture on earth has and in
many cases continues to practice child
sacrifice and we increasingly are
practicing child sacrifice the only
thing that has distinguished us is
that we are a christian civilization
or at least we were now it would appear
that we are not exactly defined by
christianity expect more child sacrifice
expect more psychos like henania and
biden and all the rest of them meanwhile
speaking of the way they're treating
your kids dr fauci wants to jab your kid
with vaccines now we know we've talked
about
risks from kovid for various groups
morbidly obese 85 year olds face a
greater risk from covid than perfectly
healthy 12 year olds
actually it's not even comparable it's
not the 12 the perfectly healthy 12 year
olds face
virtually no risk very very little risk
the 85 year old faces significantly
greater risk doesn't matter got to jab
your kids
now that the vaccine has full approval
from the fda the the pfizer vaccine
would you like to see it mandated for
students elsewhere in the u.s and once
it's approved for kids under 12 should
it be mandated for them too
you know i know that a lot of people
will be pushing back against that but if
you get the imprimatur about the safety
and the strong benefit risk ratio for
the children when that gets established
which i believe it certainly will
by the fda and the acip i believe that
mandating vaccines for children to
appear in school is a good idea and
remember jake this is not something new
we have mandates in many places in
schools particularly public schools that
if in fact you want a child to come in
we've done this for decades and decades
requiring polio measles mumps rubella
hepatitis so this would not be something
new requiring vaccinations for children
to come to school
so dishonest so dishonest polio
smallpox all these sorts of
uh diseases that he was told measles
whatever these are associated with very
negative outcomes for children those are
diseases that pose a great risk to
children coronavirus is not
talk about child sacrifice
the actual argument for
vaccine all the kids is not that it's
really going to help the kids out it's
not even that there are no risks to the
kids we know that there are risks to the
kids the cdc and the fda have admitted
that
it's that it'll be better for the old
people
it'll be better for us
the kids i don't know we're gonna take
some risks with the kids but it'll be
better for us
sick
sick stuff
i believe the other problem with with
fouchy suggesting this is he just
doesn't have any credibility one of the
defining features of vauch's career is
that he's obsessed with vaccines and he
doesn't focus on treatments there are
treatments for coronavirus that have
shown some promise but fauci has never
focused on treatment of illnesses he's
just obsessed with creating vaccines
they did this during aids that she put
basically no focus on on therapeutics on
treatments for aids and the consequences
of aids he put all of the focus on a
vaccine here we are decades and decades
later we still don't have a vaccine and
yet people don't die from aids
virtually ever anymore
at least not for a very very long time
why is that because of therapeutics
because finally mostly private companies
focused on creating treatments for aids
and that was what allowed people to live
and you're seeing the same idiocy play
out now there have been proposed
treatments for coronavirus that have
shown some success i know you're not
allowed to really talk about that
anymore but they have shown some success
and in various mixtures and i'm not i'm
not favoring one over the other but
people have tried treating coronava my
doctor has treated people with the
coronavirus
and
it's worked out for them they've
recovered even when they were not
looking so great
now
because we have a guy at the head of
niaid who's vaccine obsessed all the
focus is on vaccines well if the guy has
a checkered career if the guy has a
record of incompetence and deception why
are we still listening to him about this
i certainly am not one of the suggested
treatments
for coronavirus is ivermectin are we
even allowed to say ivermectin anymore
on on camera i'm not joe rogan came out
yesterday he said look i got kovid and
then i threw a bunch of stuff at it you
know this that the other thing
ivermecton was one of them and then i
had one bad day and now i feel great
and then all the libs
one were hoping that he would die i
think i i don't think that's an
exaggeration
i
i'm not saying it was prominent libs but
there were a lot of libs i saw in the
comments sections and on twitter we're
saying yeah i would serve him right it
would serve his spread disinformation i
hope he gets the worst he can get
but at the even the ones who were not
wishing that joe would die or face
serious complications were making fun of
him they were making fun of him for
taking all these treatments including
ivermectin
ivor oh you idiot joe
you were taking a horse tranquilizer
that's what npr said they wrote
the podcast host joe rogan who has
dismissed covid vaccines said he tested
positive and is taking a cocktail of
unproven treatments
i think it just got proven bro
including ivermectin a deworming drug
for cows that the fda warns people not
to ingest
that's just a lie that's just fake news
they could and the geniuses over at npr
couldn't even google ivermectin which is
a draw i'm not saying it's approved for
using coronavirus it is an fda approved
drug for human use not only that it has
been called in major
scientific journals
a wonder drug very very recently
joe rogan that idiot rube
he took the deworming horse drug
ivermectin
and he recovered very very quickly like
way quicker than we said that you can
recover from this thing wow what an
idiot right
so on this point of ivermectin i'm not
i am not talk to your doctors okay i'm
not saying i vermectin cures coronavirus
or anything like that
i am just pointing out
that before
trump
before
conservatives
suggested that maybe ivermectin had
antiviral qualities
everyone was calling this thing
a wonder drug here we i read
one abstract from the nih yesterday
here's one published in nature it's from
the journal of antibiotics this was
published february 15 2017 ivermectin
enigmatic multifaceted wonder drug
continues to surprise and exceed
expectations the guy who discovered this
won the nobel prize for goodness sakes
2015 nobel prize
the the
drug is in part for suppressing things
like lice or sure suppressing things
like worms but it also has observed
antiviral qualities and as we read
yesterday there have even been some
experiments to show its use on
coronavirus and that it was effective
though the question that remains is what
would the dosage be with the dosage have
to be so high that it would be toxic for
humans so maybe that's why we can't
suggest it but to say
now that this what was previously being
called a wonder drug that led to a guy
winning the nobel prize that shows
anti-viral qualities
now to write it off as just a silly
horse dewormer
obviously has nothing to do with science
it is a consequence of the orange man
being bad it shows you how
grave a threat a
global pandemic you might say trump
derangement syndrome is that we are now
mocking and deriding and throwing aside
one of the greatest scientific
breakthroughs in recent decades
ivermectin
just because some trump supporters
suggested maybe it's good at suppressing
viruses
that is really sick when our
lust for vengeance
and our lust to own our perceived
enemies and when i say are i'm not i'm
not really talking about ours i'm
talking about the left's perception that
we are their enemies when they're lust
to own us and smack us down is so great
that they're going to throw out a great
scientific breakthrough
something has gone seriously sick in the
country tds by the way does not just
affect
the left as i pointed out
it affects the right too paul ryan
former republican speaker of the house
former rising star in the republican
party
is making a point to go on tv and still
all these months later say trump trump
lost biden one stopped ever saying there
was anything wrong with the election
please find one
president trump lost the election joe
biden won the election it was not rigged
it was not stolen donald trump lost the
election joe biden won the election he
exhausted his cases he exhausted the
court challenges
none of them went his direction um and
so he legitimately lost is there are
there is there mischief in shenanigans
in elections
sure is there fraud yes was it organized
to the extent that would have swung the
electoral college in the presidential
election absolutely not
absolutely not hi i'm paul ryan and i am
going to devote as much time and energy
as i possibly can to
convincing everyone that the democrat
president is totally above board i
because i'm a republican
it's weird it's weird that he would
spend so much energy
focusing on
left-wing talking points also one of the
things he said is just patently not true
so he says the election was not stolen i
don't know if the election was stolen or
not you're right he's right there there
were court challenges they didn't
present proof so okay yeah i don't know
i'm not willing to say the election was
still 100 definitively the election was
i'm not going to say that
the election for sure was rigged
for sure
it's that's undeniable they changed all
the election rules in the weeks before
the election to favor democrats and to
take away election integrity measures
and in at least one state they violated
the state constitution to do it with the
widespread use of male and ballots in
pennsylvania
for sure there was double counting of
ballots in just one batch in just one
county in georgia that we only found
because conservatives keep raising these
questions so please paul ryan shut up
i don't look you can have your view i'm
not i don't mean to i don't want to be
disrespectful or uncivil or anything
like that
but
the
questions that people have raised about
the 2020 election are perfectly
legitimate the investigations that are
still going on have uncovered fairly
widespread problems at least in
individual batches and individual
precincts and individual counties
in states that joe biden according to
the official tally barely won
so
sure you can have you you're perfectly
fine to have your view that the election
wasn't stolen and to point out that
trump didn't prove that the election was
stolen absolutely right
but
if you're not going to help people
on your
putative side
raise legitimate questions and try to
fight to make sure that there aren't
shenanigans and fraud in the next
election
then just do nothing at all
just sit back
it's it's so frustrating to me though
when people who have
built their careers on the support of
republicans and conservatives
not only turn their backs not only
step out of the fight
but actively work to undermine those
conservatives not just when the
conservatives are being unjust and crazy
but even when conservatives are raising
legitimate questions and pursuing
investigations that one are uncovering
some fraud but two are not interfering
with the government it's not a coup
d'etat it's not an insurrection
it's really really frustrating this is i
used to really admire paul ryan i used
to really admire some of what he was
trying to do at least as it pertained to
reforming the administrative state and
the entitlement programs
but tds takes down even the best of them
it's really really frustrating
really really frustrating there is a big
win though i've got a
i've got to get to before we go john
mcarthur john mcarthur is a
protestant i think he's baptist a
baptist preacher in california you
haven't met him he's very very amiable
man he uh
he stood up against the covid lockdowns
he stood up against the local government
and the state government and and he
refused to shut down he referred to his
church services as a peaceful protest
during the lockdown i loved it and he
was doing it when other churches
wouldn't even when bishops wouldn't even
some some of the parishes in my church
wouldn't do it the catholic church
and he stood up and he was fined and the
government tried to shut down his church
well he just won a big settlement
the
l.a county board of supervisors is going
to pay him 400 grand and the state of
california is going to pay him 400 grand
because he had the right
to hold his church services and the
government had no right to shut him down
and he was willing to take the risk and
take the fines and now the government's
paying up i love it great stuff
congratulations to john mcarthur some
really good news this week some really
good news to winning back the culture
our october episode of backstage is
going to be a little different i think
i've told you this before instead of
just tuning in from your home
you're going to be able to see us live
and on stage at the famous ryman
auditorium right here in nashville so
join me candace owens jeremy bourne
bench bureau matt walsh drew clavin
for backstage like never before pre-sale
tickets sold out within hours yesterday
and general admission tickets went on
sale at 10 am today we are offering
three different kinds of tickets there
are vip tickets that come with an
exclusive gift and a meet and greet with
us the dw hosts
followed by a ticket that comes with
upgraded seating and a show poster
finally tickets for general seating
whichever ticket you choose i guarantee
it's going to be a good time hurry
though head to dailywire.com ryman
r-y-m-a-n
to purchase your tickets before they
sell out
they really did they sold out much more
quickly even than we thought yesterday
for the pre-sale
so go if you if you want to come and i
hope you do i hope we'll see you there
but if you do want to get a ticket i
would do it like now
we'll be right back with the mailbag
welcome back to my favorite time of the
week the mailbag first question from
andrew michael love the show but i must
clog your inbox with another
relationship question sorry
that's all right this is this is what i
live for the first part of the show
is political philosophy
statecraft policy
theology then the second part during the
mailbag is uh dr phil
i'm just sometimes jerry springer
okay
this person writes
i'm a christian guy who didn't plan on
being single well into his 30s but i'm
here and i'm second guessing the why and
how my dating life has generally fallen
into the following dilemma either the
gal is physically attractive but largely
uninteresting in conversation or the
reverse interesting and fun to talk to
but i'm not attracted to her what do you
think am i holding out for an
unattainable prize or should i trust
that god can bring along someone who i
enjoy spending time with and who think
who i think is the hottest woman on two
legs signed i'd be unhappily single i'd
rather be unhappily single than
unhappily married
well i will tell you buddy
this is going to be hard for you to hear
i did marry someone who i enjoy spending
time with who i think is very
intelligent and interesting to talk to
and who i also think is the hottest
woman on two legs it actually did work
out for me i don't think it works out
for everybody but it did for me and i
don't want to brag but i just want to
tell you that is possible or you hear
drew talk about talk about his wife and
you know that guy he sounds like a 16
year old boy and i think he's a little
older than 16 at this point you know uh
so it can happen and i think it's
important
of course looks are going to fade my
friend looks are going to fade and also
when you're
when you're thinking about well am i
always going to be totally sexually
turned you know i'm never going to be
sexually attracted to anyone else people
just men in general are going to be
sexually attracted to a lot of things i
mean that's not that's not going to
change you're going to see a woman walk
by and you're going to feel an
attraction to her
regardless you mean you could be dating
the hottest woman on planet earth and
you'll still feel an attraction to other
women
partially because the imagination of
man's heart is evil from the beginning
and also because men like variety and
because men you know are just attracted
to hot way that's just how it goes okay
so
yes it's important that you find your
wife attractive
but recognizing that looks will fade
over time it is much
much more important that you guys see
eye to eye that you see the world in a
basically similar way that you have the
same idea of what marriage even is
that's a really important one because if
you go in with one view of marriage you
know let's say it's a biblical view of
marriage and then the woman goes in with
let's say a feminist view of marriage
this is you're just not even getting
into the same institution i mean that's
going to be a really big problem
but i i would hold out and i think
don't fall into the tr the swipe trap
okay don't fall into the big city trap
of
you don't value the women that you are
with because you you know that there's
always good there's always going to be a
hotter woman on the app
you could be dating the hottest woman in
the world but there's going to be some
other woman is going to come along at
some point and she's going to be the
hottest and okay so
or you're talking to a woman you think
she's really interesting and just really
cool and you get along but then you meet
some other woman and oh my gosh she
shares this passion of yours
this is what happened to my friends in
the big cities who didn't leave the big
cities
a lot of them got caught in the swipe
prep there's always someone better so
i'm not going to invest in the person
that i'm with and a lot of what's going
to make a relationship and a marriage is
going to be
shared experience it's going to be
growing together which is going to make
you love that person even more and and
be even more attracted to that person
you hear this sometimes with happily
married couples at the end of their
lives they've been married 60 years or
something and they'll say i am more
attracted to my wife today than i was
when we on the day that we got married
they're not just blowing smoke that is
actually how it works because it's a
real marriage is a real thing that
you're getting into so
do it
don't act like a man you're gonna act
like a man what's the matter with you do
it you know don't don't make a mistake
but don't hem and haw and keep waiting
for the perfect person to come along for
the whole rest of your life because then
you're going to miss out on marriage
from emily dear michael i'm going to get
a little saucy here with my question
here we go i'm newly married and am very
much enjoying the honeymoon phase if
you're picking up what i'm putting down
okay okay
uh it's a great time
this is a family show i don't know if i
can even read this question all right
whatever i'll just that's fine
maybe close your kids ears until you
hear this question it's a great time but
i want to have more of a dumb and
submissive bedroom feel my husband isn't
into the idea though it says it
though and he says it makes him
uncomfortable i'm not willing to give up
on it but he's very adamant it seems in
not taking a dom roll
should he just man up and take the more
trad role of being the dominant one in
the relationship into the bedroom or are
my wants a little much sincerely does s
m stand for saints and mary wow that's
actually
rather than being sacrilegious i think
that's that signature is actually kind
of getting to your question which is
if i've got these kind of kinky sexual
desires can that be virtuous and good
and right or is it always going to be
sinful
yes your husband is the head of
household yes he should be
confident and assertive and
trad
but you don't want it to be
you don't want it to be sadomasochism i
mean that's that's the question right s
m is it saints and mary sadomasochism is
wrong it's bad it's disordered to want
to hurt yourself
sadism or masochism rather and it's
disordered to want to hurt another
person sadism to get pleasure from the
pain of another person and it's
especially disordered to
want to get pleasure from the pain of
your wife i mean that's especially
disordered
so
i would not do that i would not feed
that particular lust or appetite
everyone's got some kinks i mean there's
no everyone's got some weird stuff that
they're into you know this is why
there's a porn for every single thing on
the internet but i don't think that it's
necessarily a good thing to
uh indulge all of that women in
particular have these fantasies this is
why
there's like chick lit right this is why
there's the romance novels and 50 shades
of grey and all of that so i'm not
saying that uh you know you can't can't
have fun and you can't have the man be a
little more assertive but i
when it gets to the point of
like i
i get a thrill out of causing you
real pain and i or i get a thrill out of
being in real pain myself
i would not i would not indulge that too
much that's
that's that is that would not be
cool with the saints and mary i would
imagine i think you know have fun have a
good time you don't need to be like
totally bland and you know
but
uh i i wouldn't i wouldn't cross that
line i don't i don't think that's i
don't think that that's just sort of
blowing off a little steam and having
fun and i think that is the sort of
vice and appetite that is that is not
going to
make you happier i think that's going to
get more extreme over time just how like
people who write in about porn they'll
say i started looking at porn and then
it i got way more extreme and weird and
eventually i was disgusted with it i
think that's kind of what happens
there which is which is why you know you
either turn your desires in a virtuous
direction or you turn them toward vice
but whichever one you do more of is it's
going to be easier to do you're going to
ultimately be more inclined to do over
time from wilson
you know that actually turned out to be
a much more serious answer to like a
weird frivolous sex question i didn't i
didn't expect it going that way but
anyway that's my answer from wilson hey
michael should something be said about
the okay
white power symbol emoji the fact that
we're even calling the okay sign the
white power symbol is so insane
uh just curious i typed it to
acknowledge a message from my buddy the
other day and i've been regretting my my
whiteness ever since stay woke and enjoy
a good smoke you know it's funny because
it's it's a joking question but now you
actually do have to think twice before
doing that a-okay you know the okay
symbol and it's because symbols
can change with use i mean
now to a great many people if i say hey
man good stuff great work
they
many hysterical libs will view that and
say that i'm you know a klansman or
something like that i guess they call me
that anyway but
this is why we've got to control the
symbols
this is why we've got to control the
language this is the whole point of my
book speechless
if if you don't then the symbols really
will take on different meanings over
time and then you've lost
the ability to communicate you've lost
you've lost your your words you are
rendered you might say speechless from
nick uh-oh
uh-oh is this i know nick is a common
name but let's see hi michael my younger
brother has been in a relationship with
a woman almost twice his age he is 23
and she is 39 i've never felt right
about the relationship she has
repeatedly lied about her past and only
recently did we find the truth about her
he recently proposed to her and still
feeling uncomfortable about the
situation we decided to do a background
check on her we found that she's been
married twice has children with both of
her ex-husbands she doesn't have custody
of any of her children she has a lot of
debt and has been charged with theft six
times i tried to tell him he's making a
mistake but he seems to be blinded by
his love for her
now that he knows that no one in his
family supports his marriage he plans to
move away and cut ties with all of us is
there anything i can do to avoid losing
a relationship with my brother thank you
for your help i've been a big fan of
your show for years sincerely not the
same nick okay
oh i'm sorry to hear about your problem
man that's really tough uh he obviously
should run run as fast as he can not
away from you but away from her there
should be a nick's brother-shaped hole
in the wall you know when he learns
these things and if you've told him this
and he still won't run away then
something's gone a little kooky in his
head
and i'm not saying that that is the
fault of the family
he's at a really precarious place
because
in the early 20s
men
can go a little crazy i mean this is
after college age you're just maybe
starting out in your career or your job
and you're really unsettled and it's
kind of a new thing and
you know throughout history men are
taken to flights of fancy in their early
20s it's just something about the male
psyche and so the i the hope is that the
mistakes you make in your late teens and
early twenties will
not be you're gonna make mistakes you're
gonna you're gonna do very bad things in
those
years most likely but the hope is that
it's not a permanent mistake and if he
gets married
it will be i mean this woman might leave
it sounds like she's kind of flighty and
dishonest
but i think all you can do
is
be there for him
in the sense that you're presenting him
with this information you still love
your brother you don't want him to go
away but i would not sanction this this
wedding i would not
i would i would not show up
i would hard as that is to say
i don't think i would show up
i'm not a hundred percent on that i'd
need to know a little bit more about the
circumstances where they are what
they're do but i
i would not
support this i would do everything you
can to stop this wedding
short of throwing a burlap sack over him
and dragging him away i would not i
would not
go along with this from charles hey
michael you said on your show today
tuesday the 31st of august that there is
no constitutional grounds for
impeachment of joe biden but i disagree
the standard of high crimes and
misdemeanors is vague deliberately so i
think as we all know in law negligence
can be criminal there's plenty of
evidence to suggest that biden ignored
all the advice of his military
commanders in this botched withdrawal
getting soldiers killed stranding u.s
citizens behind enemy lines leaving
billions of dollars of high grade
military equipment to an enemy etc
i agree that mere incompetence is not
impeachable but this is beyond
incompetence this is criminal
recklessness thanks love the show it's a
clever argument but i just don't buy it
i just don't buy it i don't i don't see
what the limiting principle of this
would be i don't see how this would not
just be used by every opposition party
for every administration to say look
we're not saying that mal administration
is impeachable but serious mal
administration is impeachable i just
don't i don't buy it i don't think
that's how the clause was understood by
the framers or anyone else that for that
matter at the time of ratification
so i wouldn't go down this road
yes we're in an age of largely
politicized
impeachments that don't even really have
a legal basis like the trump
impeachments but i also don't see the
benefit of impeaching biden
then we get president harris i think
that's worse so i i just i wouldn't go
down that road from sam dear michael i
just started my senior year at brigham
young university being a stem major at a
major at a majority conservative
university i've been extremely lucky
that i've avoided the rampant cancer of
wokeness that has invaded most campuses
however i am in an 1877 to present u.s
history class and it is as woke as they
come
i have very specific circumstances that
have locked me into this class and this
professor so i can't get out of it what
is it a cute girl or something
do you have any advice on getting
through this social indoctrination
course without me getting failed for
disagreeing with this reconstruction of
history loved your book glad i was able
to finish it before class i've taken
woke history classes before i mean one
of my senior advisors was a very woke
professor who now frequently publicly
criticizes me she also publicly
criticizes ben sasse who was another
student of hers and i think she just
like gets a thrill i think out of
publicly criticizing her former students
but at the time that i was a student of
hers she was very polite she knew that i
was very conservative she was fine with
it
so i i would i would stick by your guns
i would take his argument seriously the
professors i would if you disagree with
them make your argument seriously i
wouldn't hide your views
and if you get a lower grade you know
that's too bad that's the cost of of
having integrity okay last question bin
you mean says michael seeing as the
mailbag has become a quasi dr phil show
i thought i'd throw my hat in the ring
i'm 19 i finished my degree in high
school and i'm currently doing a year of
religious studies i'm jewish before i
enlist for a whole bunch of years i
didn't date throughout high school since
i was always busy but now i'm wondering
if it may be time to start sincerely
it's all about the benjamins
it's all about the binya means yes
it is time to start bro i mean you're
still you know you're not over the hill
you're 19. right so it's not like oh i
gave up my youth to date but yeah you
should date you should date it's good
for a man to date better for a man to
get married sounds like you got a good
good career good head on your shoulders
do it absolutely i'm michael nosis the
michael noll show i'll see you guys next
week
[Music]
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies executive producer jeremy
bora our technical director is austin
stevens supervising producer mathis
glover production manager pavel vadovsky
editor and associate producer danny
d'amico associate producer justine
turley audio mixer mike coromina and
hair and makeup by nica geneva the
michael knowles show is a daily wire
production copyright dailywire 2021. hey
everybody this is andrew clavin host of
the andrew clavin show you know some
people are depressed because the
republic is collapsing the end of days
is approaching and the moons turn to
blood but on the andrew clavin show
that's where the fun just gets started
so come on over to the andrew clavin
show and laugh your way through the fall
of the republic with me andrew clavin